[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
ihren apps herzlich willkommen was den
sport angeht bringt sie norbert lehmann
auf den neuesten stand guten haben doch
von mir bleiben wir auf die großen
themen heute in den nachrichten
heftige gefechte kiew das russische
militär kommt kaum voran und die ukraine
starten weitere gegenangriffe
generaldebatte im zeichen des krieges
oppositionsführer märz und bundeskanzler
scholz streiten über den haushalt im
bundestag
und zu warmen ewigen eis nirgendwo
steigen die temperaturen so schnell wie
am nordpol
zur abschreckung russlands will die nato
weitere kampftruppen in den östlichen
mitgliedsländern stationieren das ganze
soll morgen beim sondergipfel der
militärallianz beschlossen werden auch
ukraine ist präsident zielinski wird per
video an dem treffen teilnehmen nach
ukrainischen angaben konnte der
russische vormarsch offenbar teilweise
gestoppt werden bluten reihenhaus und
christoph distel berichten
diese aufnahmen sollen zeigen dass
ukrainische armee und paramilitärs mit
gegenangriffen begonnen haben wie hier
vor den toren kiels
bilder der ukrainischen seite deren
echtheit wir so gut wie möglich
verifiziert haben
nordwestlich von kiew sei der russische
vormarsch ins stocken geraten
insbesondere in butter ihre pin und
ostrow mail zu informationen der
ukrainischen armee
hier sei es nach heftigen gefechten
gelungen russischen panzer einheiten
schwere verluste zuzufügen und sie vom
nachschub abzuschneiden
die schweren kämpfe haben offenbar auf
beiden seiten viele menschenleben
gekostet alleine in diesem massengrab
nahe butter wurden 67 tote begraben
militärische erfolge der ukraine
bestätigen auch beobachter im westen die
russischen truppen sind in der pause
sind in einer schwierigen situation im
westen und norden auch im süden hat die
ukrainische armee in der letzten woche
den gegenangriff gemacht hat ziemlich
erfolgreich war um kiew
letzte nacht und gestern
wir sehen anzeichen dafür dass die
ukraine gerade etwas mehr in die
offensive gehen dabei gehen sie sehr
geschickt vor überraschend und kreativ
und an orten die sie dafür geeignet
halten
an der schwarzmeerküste soll es nahe der
stadt carson sowie nordöstlich von
odessa gelungen sein der russischen
armee niederlage zuzufügen
in der stadt präsenz sprengten die
bewohner nach eigenen angaben selbst
eine brücke um die angreifenden panzer
zu stoppen
es war eine kolossale anstrengung der
ganzen stadt wir benutzten jagdgewehre
die leute warfen ziegelsteine alte
frauen haben sandsäcke befüllt
wohl als reaktion auf den stockenden
vormarsch hat russland die luftangriffe
intensiviert und feuert raketen nun
verstärkt von schiffen aus
unsere operation verläuft strikt nach
plan und noch sind ziele nicht erreicht
wie das militärische potenzial der
ukraine ausschalten
nach wochenlangem beschuss sieht das
besonders heftig umkämpfte mario pohl
heute so aus russische panzer sind
bereits in der hafenstadt vollständig
erobert ist sie bislang nicht
und das mit russland verbündete belarus
hat jetzt die ukraine aufgefordert fast
ihr gesamtes diplomatisches personal aus
belarus abzuziehen binnen 72 stunden
außerdem wurde das ukrainische
konsulaten belarussischen brest
geschlossen und für uns in der ukraine
ist jörg brase jörg wie wird dieser
schritt des nachbarlandes belarus bei
ihnen beurteilt
jawohl auch als retourkutsche für die
forderungen von präsident syrien ski
noch härtere sanktionen zu verhängen
gegen den russland verbündeten belarus
die regierung in kiew hat angekündigt
dass sie auf die entscheidung von heute
entsprechend reagieren will es gibt dem
ukrainischen generalstab aber einige die
glauben dass barroso gar ein
militärisches eingreifen
vorbereitet man habe beobachtet heißt es
dass militärisches material auf
russischem gebiet entlang der
ukrainischen grenze
transportiert würde und dass tatsächlich
belarus eingreifen könnte was wohl auch
einige in der nato befürchten die
glauben dass sich belarus militärisch
engagieren könnte ein bisschen lang aber
ist präsident lukaschenka davor
zurückgeschreckt eben aufgrund von angst
vor weiteren sanktionen trotz der
forderung moskaus
ob sich daran nun etwas geändert hat das
muss man jetzt in den nächsten tagen
beobachten nämlich ob neben
militärischem material auch truppen
entlang der ukrainischen grenze
stationiert werden der blase in lemberg
dankeschön
schauen wir direkt nach moskau denn
russische gaslieferungen sollen künftig
in rubel abgerechnet werden das sagte
präsident putin während einer
kabinettssitzung
das gelte für lieferungen in so wörtlich
unfreundliches starten russland werde
seinen vertraglichen verpflichtungen bei
der menge und den preisen nachkommen die
änderungen betreffen nur die währung so
putin
offenbar eine retourkutsche für die
sanktionen frank bethmann an der
frankfurter börse wie kommt das in der
wirtschaft an ja die deutsche
gaswirtschaft zeigt sich in einer ersten
stellungnahme irritiert vermutlich sogar
überrascht wie im übrigen auch viele
hier an der börse damit hatte man nicht
gerechnet putin versucht mit diesem
schachzug die eigene währung zu stärken
seit kriegsbeginn stürzte der rubel
zeitweise ins bodenlose verliert vor
allem gegenüber dem us-dollar kräftig
heute nun die gegenbewegung die
russische währung mit knapp 9 prozent im
plus dazu muss man wissen dass es an den
internationalen devisenmärkten gar nicht
genug trubel gibt um künftig alle öl-
und gaslieferungen mit der russischen
währung zu begleichen
also sind westliche banken vermutlich
gezwungen bei der russischen zentralbank
anzuklopfen aber das perverse daran ist
twitterte top-ökonomen jeden zug um die
russische zentralbank ist der
eigentliche sanktioniert dadurch zwingt
uns putin somit indirekt unsere eigenen
sanktionen zu unterlaufen
derzeit ist völlig unklar wie der westen
auf diesen unerwarteten schritt
reagieren wird dankeschön frank bethmann
deutschland will der ukraine jetzt
weitere 2000 panzerfäuste aus den
beständen der bundeswehr liefern die
meldung kommt nur wenige stunden nachdem
es in der generaldebatte im bundestag
neben dem haushalt vor allem um den
ukraine krieg ging die generaldebatte
gilt als höhepunkt der
haushaltsberatungen dieses mal bestimmt
von den folgen des russischen angriffs
ein bericht von winnie heescher guten
morgen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
die sitzung eröffnete olaf scholz ist
spät dran auch mit einer antwort an den
ukrainischen präsidenten vor sechs tagen
hatte sie lenski deutschland hier um
hilfe gebeten heute verspricht scholz
allgemein unterstützung klarer definiert
er grenzen deutscher hilfsbereitschaft
präsident zielinski die ukraine kann
sich auf unsere hilfe verlassen
überall wo man derzeit mit bürgern und
bürgern spricht begegnet einem früher
oder später die frage
wird es krieg geben auch hier bei uns
auf
diese frage kann es nur eine antwort
geben die nato wird nicht kriegspartei
da sind wir uns mit unseren europäischen
verbündeten und den vereinigten staaten
eine auf die schärfere tonlage mit der
friedrich merz die debatte begonnen hat
steigt scholz nicht ein die koalition
braucht für ihre bundeswehr pläne
stimmen der union märz will das nutzen
die cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion ist nicht
die ersatzbank von der sie sich
beliebiger weise mal ersatzspieler auf
die fährte wenn sie ihre eigenen werte
das gilt für alle vor einschließlich
einschließlich der insel damit es klar
die geplanten 100 milliarden für die
bundeswehr sieht rennen opposition und
regierung
ja wir müssen mehr investieren in die
sicherheit und wir müssen mehr
investieren in die ausrüstung der
bundeswehr
es geht um die verteidigungsfähigkeit
deutschlands aber vor allem um die
frauen und männer die bereit sind hier
in deutschland ihr leben für unsere
freiheit zu riskieren wie soll die neue
bundeswehr eigentlich personell aussehen
auch das muss ja mal debattiert und
diskutiert denn bevor man über weitere
kosten und weitere summen sprechen die
schulden der bundeswehr sind die
streichungen bei sozialer sicherheit
wenn sie nicht den mut haben endlich bei
den vermögenden etwas abzugreifen eine
debatte die einst gezeigt hat es gibt
noch viel zu erklären um zu überzeugen
aufrüsten für den frieden über diese
frage diskutiert zdf heute live unter
anderem mit der theologin margot käßmann
um 19.30 in der zdf- heute- app und auf
unseren social media kanälen wie
die menschen in deutschland angesichts
der enorm gestiegenen energiekosten
entlastet werden können darüber beraten
die ampel parteien am abend in berlin im
gespräch unter anderem einen rabatt auf
tankrechnungen ebenso ein mobilitäts
geld um vor allem die kosten für
berufspendler rinnen und händler zu
reduzieren und auch über eine senkung
von steuern auf energie produkte wird
nachgedacht
einige vorschläge als account manager in
welche richtung steuert die ampel
koalition das weist die ampel wurst und
zur stunde selber noch nicht so ganz
genau denn die fachpolitiker die das
ganze entscheiden sollten in den letzten
tagen die konnten sich noch nicht auf
ein modell einigen deswegen geht das
ganze jetzt in den koalitionsausschuss
wird also chefsache dort beraten die
spitzen von partei regierung und
fraktion was wir hören ist dass sich ein
kompromiss abzeichnen könnte der dafür
sorgen soll dass das ganze niedrigere
und mittlere einkommen stärker entlastet
damit wäre der tank rabatt den christian
lindner ins gespräch gebracht hat
wahrscheinlich raus der wurde ja vor
allem dafür kritisiert dass er auch
menschen mit hohem einkommen
entlastet und zwar überdurchschnittlich
das ganze soll jetzt heute besprochen
werden und was auf dem tisch liegt sind
momentan zwei vorschläge zeitlich
befristet ein monatliches mobilitäts
geld oder eine einmalige energiekosten
pauschale das ist das was wir hören aber
es gibt viel diskussionsbedarf im detail
nicht nur zu diesem punkt sondern auch
zu vielen anderen denn was heute beraten
wird soll ein großes paket seien eine
quadratur des kreises der schnelle
ausstieg aus russischen billigen
rohstoffen bei gleichzeitigem erhalt von
sozial- und umweltverträglichkeit und da
gibt es eine menge diskussionsbedarf wir
hören dass es eine lange nacht sitzung
wird ein lange nachtsitzungen sie wären
das für uns beobachten dankeschön
container bennati
der krieg in der ukraine die steigenden
preise das bremst auch den
wirtschaftlichen aufschwung in
deutschland für das laufende jahr
rechnet das ifo-institut nur noch mit
einem wirtschaftswachstum zwischen 2,2
und 3,1 prozent ursprünglich war von 3,7
prozent ausgegangen worden und inflation
könnte auf 5,1 bis 6,1 prozent steigen
zuletzt erwartete das ifo institut noch
eine inflation von 3,3 prozent
zu corona da steigt die zahl der
neuinfektionen in deutschland weiter an
das robert koch institut meldet eine
inzidenz von
1734 2
1732 neue fälle wurden innerhalb eines
tages registriert das sind 21.000 139
mehr als vergangenen mittwoch
329 todesfälle kam dazu
millionen kinder gehen tag für tag in
die schule und die eltern glauben dass
sie dort gut aufgehoben sind aber
schulen können auch zum tatort für
sexualisierte gewalt werden eine
kommission hat betroffene aufgerufen
über ihre erlebnisse zu berichten
gemeldet haben sich 160 schüler innen
vielen schilderung ist gemeinsam die
täter und täterinnen werden oft erst
spät zur rechenschaft gezogen
henriette de maizière
lars wellings wir reden über seine
erfahrung mit sexualisierter gewalt
ein lehrer hat ihnen missbraucht
bedrängt gedemütigt über viele jahre die
geschichte ist das ein hochrangiger
stellvertretender schuldirektor
systematisch jungen im alter vielleicht
zwischen 11 so wie ich damals war und 14
sexuell missbraucht hat beim fühlt sich
ausgeliefert wenn man macht das einfach
mal sagt steht dann vor der schule und
sagt du ich habe gedacht wir fahren
jetzt einfach mal zu mir weil es ist
irgendwie gemütlich ja ja und dann
schließt er irgendwann die tür hinter
sich ab und dann passieren dinge die
natürlich nicht in ordnung sind
heute öffentliches hearing der
aufarbeitung kommission in berlin den
betroffenen zu hören dem erlebten
gewicht geben auch viele jahre später
das sei das eine schutzkonzepte das
andere doch es hapert an der umsetzung
und zwar eigentlich in katastrophalen
maße also wir haben einen monitoring
gemacht
2018 und er wurde festgestellt dass nur
13 prozent der schulen in der
bundesrepublik das umgesetzt haben viele
betroffene berichten es hätte momente
der wendung geben können wenn jemand den
mut gehabt hätte zu helfen angebote wie
das hilfs telefon sexueller missbrauch
die gibt es sie müssen mit dem thema
nicht alleine bleiben aber was sie
müssen ist sie müssen auf kinder achten
und die dürfen sie nicht allein lassen
aber sie können sich hilfe holen sie
müssen dann nicht alleine durch lars
wellings weiß heute es waren mindestens
fünf schüler allein in seinem jahrgang
betroffen auch für sie macht der seine
geschichte öffentlich
viele mädchen in afghanistan hatten sich
auf diesen tag gefreut nach den
landesweiten ferien sollten sie wieder
in die schule dürfen aber die taliban
zogen ihre zusage zurück nur die
wenigsten weiterführenden schulen wie
hier in kabul öffnete heute morgen für
die mädchen die meisten blieben
geschlossen die un sprachen von einem
rückschlag für mädchen und ihre zukunft
ein globales problem ist durch corona
und der ukraine krieg in den hintergrund
gerückt und zwar die klimakrise die akte
spielt dabei eine besondere rolle sie
erwärmt sich viel stärker als andere
regionen der erde im durchschnitt der
letzten 50 jahre um zwei bis drei grad
celsius und in den nächsten jahrzehnten
droht gar ein temperaturanstieg um bis
zu 14 grad mit drastischen folgen für
das wetter auch bei uns unser
meteorologe ist intel hat auf
spitzbergen klima forschende des alfred
wegener instituts getroffen
der sturm kam aus südlichen breiten in
die arktis und brachte milde luft das
bedeutet schneefall dann folgte direkt
wieder sonnenschein und eisige kälte vom
arktischen ozean der rasche wechsel von
extremen gegensätzen hat zugenommen so
die wissenschaftler was früher eher
gleichmäßig war ist jetzt anders das
untersuchen wissenschaftler mit
flugzeugen und messgeräten in den
verschiedenen luftschichten
wir sind in apulien ein
forschungsflugzeug des
alfred-wegener-instituts über den wolken
hier werden die messungen gemacht die
dann anschließend mit und stationen und
modellen abgeglichen werden die kampagne
auf spitzbergen ist hauptsächlich auf
die vorgänge in der atmosphäre bezogen
aber die veränderungen sind
allgegenwärtig auch ohne messinstrumente
zu sehen das klima der arktis ändert
sich so besonders auch in spitzbergen
wir sehen dass besonders drastisch hier
und sofort der ist jetzt offen ich habe
es also vor 30 jahren erlebt dass ich
hier drüber laufen konnte in den 90er
jahren für früher froh der regelmäßig zu
und jetzt passiert es noch sehr selten
der starke temperaturanstieg in der
arktis beeinflusst die luftströmungen
und so wird das wetter extreme nicht nur
in der arktis sondern auch in europa und
bei uns in deutschland denn was in der
arktis passiert bleibt nicht in der
arktis
extremwetterereignisse mit
schwerwiegenden dürren stark regenfällen
und überflutungen aber auch hitzewellen
sind die folge die noch erhabene
schönheit dieser landschaft darf uns
also nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen dass
alle veränderungen in dieser region
massive folgen haben und das weltweit
ein außeneinsatz für astronauten und
astronauten auf der iss ist gefährlich
und anstrengend zugleich der deutsche
andreas maurer war jetzt zum ersten mal
dran gemeinsam mit dem us amerikaner
hashani führte er wartungsarbeiten an
der internationalen raumstation aus in
rund 400 kilometern über der erde seit
november arbeitet der deutsche auf dem
außenposten der menschheit im april geht
es dann zurück zur erde
und da kommen jetzt der fußball
nationalmannschaft noch aber die hat ja
so ein ganz besonderes training gerade
hinter rea neulich die dreierkette oder
die viererkette war das thema sondern
die ketten der unfreiheit das dfb team
bekam gestern abend besuch unter anderem
von amnesty international es ging um die
menschenrechtssituation im fußball wm
gastgeberland katar sie wollen sich auch
in politischen fragen positionieren
deshalb wurden ins quartier vertreter
von human rights watch und anders die
international eingeladen die experten
informierten über die lage beim
umstrittenen wm gastgeber und es war
einfach richtig gut dass wir jetzt
wirklich mal die absoluten experten auch
hier hatten mit ihnen uns auszutauschen
auch nur fragen zu stellen oder solaris
bei der info veranstaltung ging es um
mindestlöhne zwangsarbeit und
menschenrechte
hoffen natürlich aber schon dass über
die verbandsarbeit vom dfb und vor allem
vom veranstalter von der fifa da auch
größere hebel eben vielleicht in
bewegung gesetzt werden um das auf jeden
fall die die menschenrechte dort vor ort
die umsetzung auch zu verbessern beim
start ins wm-jahr feld sabri mit einer
erkältung aus für ihn wurde heute julian
brand nachnominiert
zur fußball frauen champions league da
haben die bayern gestern abend im
viertelfinal hinspiel zuhause gegen
paris st germain mit 1 2 verloren
trotzdem zuversicht bei den
münchnerinnen für das rückspiel in einer
woche
enttäuschung und hoffnung bei den bayern
frauen knappe niederlage trotz
überlegenen spiels gegen paris zweimal
marie antoinette card otto nicht zu
bremsen von der bayern-defensive die
mittelstürmerin trifft in der 19 und 71
die münchnerinnen noch mit dem
anschlusstreffer nach schönem freistoß
von klara buhl fünf minuten vor
spielende
es war wichtig dass wir das 2 1 gemacht
haben weil die aufträge gibt ja gott sei
dank jetzt nicht mehr das thema zwar mit
dem rückstand nach paris aber das ist
nicht vorbei mehr zuversicht als
enttäuschung also beim fc bayern ob es
reicht wissen wir nächsten mittwoch
die tennis-weltranglisten-erste ashley
partie hat überraschend ihr karriereende
bekannt gegeben begründung der 25
jährigen australierin auf instagram ich
bin verbraucht und möchte künftig
anderen träumen nach party ist seit 114
wochen die nummer eins der tenniswelt
und hatte jüngst die australian open
gewonnen
das was vom sport dankeschön arbeit und
welche lottozahlen wurden gezogen hier
sind sie die gewinnzahlen lauten in 3 12
15 30 39 43 und die superzahl ist die
acht weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 5 157
das trockene frühlingswetter hält auch
morgen noch durch man sich daran etwas
ändert
das erfahren sie gleich von katja hornuf
christian sieh was steht für sie mit dem
heute-journal bereit um 21.45
interviewter auch petro poroschenko den
ehemaligen präsidenten der ukraine
auf wiedersehen einen schönen abend noch
[Musik]
guten abend heute ist welttag der
meteorologie der welt wetter tag steht
jedes jahr unter einem besonderen motto
in diesem jahr unter dem motto wetter
frühwarnung über mitteleuropa gibt es
derzeit keine wetterwarnungen höchstes
vor der dürre vor der trockenheit anders
sieht das über der iberischen halbinsel
aus da dreht sich ein tief und bringt
kräftige regenfälle bei uns war es heute
europaweit mit am wärmsten in bad
mergentheim und regensburg stiegen die
temperaturen knapp bis 21 grad und auch
die nachttemperaturen ändern sich etwas
am niederrhein sinken sie nicht unter 7
grad kälter wird es am alpenrand mit
minus 4 grad wieder ist der himmel
komplett klar selten bildes sich etwas
nebel oder dunst und hat sich so ein
nebel fällt mal gebildet dann ist es
morgen über tag auch ganz schnell weg
dank der frühlingssonne die temperaturen
morgen liegen an der nordsee bei 10 an
der ostsee bei 14 und dem binnenland bei
15 bis 20 grad in den nächsten tagen
ändert sich ganz wenig im norden
allerdings werden die wolken etwas
zahlreicher und es wird noch etwas
kühler von norden so liegen die
höchsttemperaturen am sonntag zwischen 9
und 20 grad ich wünsche ihnen noch einen
schönen abend